Oh
you
hey guys this is Benny for new media
rockstars calm today I am here with the
man the myth the legend Tim Ferriss
successful internet entrepreneur and a
new york times bestselling author as
well so thanks for joining us today yeah
my pleasure thanks for having me so um
you know my first question is uh you
know let me get this straight you're
successful internet entrepreneur you're
a New York Times bestselling author a
guinness world record holder a Chinese
boxing national champion and you sleep
like what six languages right five on a
really good day yeah depends on the day
four or five what are you compensating
for oh my god yeah well so there's a lot
of compensating for but what I think a
lot of people miss is that you know I'm
very good at writing a bio for myself
number one but number two is that most
of those things the vast majority of
things on that entire list of only
happened in the last like five years or
so so it's it's really been a matter of
getting the right recipe for me for
approaching learning skills to make that
as fast as possible so that's sort of
the SAG is the gist of my latest
obsession but yeah it's it's because I
have a method for approaching these
things it's not because I have any
special skill like for instance not to
jump right into it but for instance like
the language stuff right the people view
me as good at languages but the reality
is where people miss is that in junior
high and so forth when I studied Spanish
for three years I didn't I completely
failed I couldn't string sentences
together couldn't have a conversation
with anyone and concluded that I was bad
for languages but I just had the I had
the wrong method and it wasn't until I
went to Japan as an exchange student for
a year my first real trip out of the US
being believe that right and I lived
with a host family I had to learn
Japanese through comic books and judo
textbooks I didn't have any classes I
had to go to regular Japanese like
physics history classes in Japanese with
without students in a 5,000 person
Japanese school and it was from that
point that I kind of started refining
the approaches to the language
acquisition and what nuts anyway yeah
it's a good buy I'm compensating for a
lot but there is a method to the madness
that's awesome
I mean like you seem to be a person that
loves like you know learning constantly
learning new things and you have your
own little approach for it so that's
awesome serious I'm curious and I like
to make other people curious that's
great um so out of all these
achievements like which one are you like
most proud of and yeah man well I mean
the first one that comes to mind I would
probably have a more lucky highbrow
response that thought about it longer
but the first one that came to mind
which is maybe the strangest was
Japanese horseback archery which I did
haha for a I for it was for a pilot for
history channel and absolutely was
broadcast and I had a week to land and
Niko Japan and learned to ride a horse
at full gallop no hands pulling hairs
off my back shooting targets the size of
dinner plates and that was really not
only challenging but really really
dangerous and it was all captured on
film you can actually find it online if
you search tim ferriss yeah boo Simon
why a busa Emmy or trial by fire which
was the name of the show that was really
unique for me because I had not only the
compressed time not only the physical
danger but I had a crew of 20 people
filming it following me around and it
added this additional pressure and weird
performance anxiety that I hadn't really
had much it before so it was really it
was really challenging but ultimately
actually had a record of it which is
cool most of the stuff I did like
there's no video there's no anything so
it's fun to actually have a video diary
of that big today that's awesome that's
really random but that's it's awesome
good time yeah well what's the next
thing you plan a dominate then I mean
like you gotta have sure you have like a
laundry list of things yeah yeah I have
a long list I mean all I will probably
make another appearance on television I
had some interesting stuff come over the
transom and there's still have a couple
of good years left of doing crazy
physical things so I'd like to like to
get that out of my system while I can
but in the short term surfing bahasa
Indonesian I'd really like to learn
Indonesian it's a cool language is
highly highly regular so you can learn
it really quickly
and what else marksmanship I was
actually just in your neck of the woods
last weekend I was in Los Angeles
studying sniping with some guys from the
LA SWAT team Wow which was fascinating
and it what's what's funny about looking
at all these skills it's not funny
what's fascinating about looking at all
these skills seem completely unrelated
is that the way you become really good
at any of them is exactly the same I
mean they're like there there is a a
blueprint they can kind of impose on all
these things whether it's you know
swimming I couldn't swim until a few
years ago and I grew up on Long Island
which is really embarrassing right on
the water and I couldn't spend or
shooting basketball I mean I quit
basketball as soon as my junior high
coach was a huge herbulock achievement
you should go back to Bristol you know
so humiliated just and I have no verte
which is true I assume that I just never
be able to play any basketball at all
until really about a year ago you know
when I was writing the 4-hour chef and
we can we can get into that but I wanted
to tackle all the skills that I had
given up on and see if I could make them
work and so I went after basketball and
like it literally i'm not getting with
the right coach and a really contrarian
way like I was getting my first three
pointers in a weekend I mean it was nut
and the fun of it is the detective work
you know like really deconstructing
things and trying to figure out where
where the the shortcuts are in a
positive way or where the like the
Archimedes levers are where you can do
some pretty cool stuff like we're
swimming you the reason I made a quantum
leap and went from literally and this is
because of the method there's a guy
named Terry Lachlan created a method
called total immersion and it basically
removes kicking so like all the
exhaustion it removes all of those
failure points so I went from two lap
maximum on doggy paddle drowning monkey
style to 20 laps for relaxation with
super easy now I can go to gym to swim
for an hour to relax it's like
meditation which is nuts because I was
always terrified of drowning that's
really cool i mean i like you i was
actually i'm actually a dyslexic tune
that actually I'm transcended like you
know through my college my high school
years and everything and I wasn't an
athlete to back then but so I actually
ended up you know putting a lot of
things that you know before I started
them just because I thought I couldn't
do it or people told me I can do it
but they don't wasn't until like
nowadays now that I have like you know
certain achievements you know I use I
was an athlete to I was a national
badminton player for a little bit and um
you know when that happened I started
being exposed so you know different
types of athletes and you know I learned
like so many different things and now
since you know what I learned in
badminton actually transcended through
all the other sports that are kind of
like to pardon like in the past but
didn't but but you know didn't
participate anymore and then I found
that you know hey like you know a lot of
these skills kind of like transfer over
and then I i was actually you know
really decent at it yeah after a while
so part so the transfer is what's really
fun so for instance you know I'm a
lifelong down cook I've always hated to
cook I've always found it really
inconvenient and time-consuming it's
just like that's why I work so I have
money so I don't have to cook you know
like that was my attitude and aha what I
realized is well number one I thought it
might be fun kind of like zen and the
art of motorcycle maintenance to take a
skull that it actually kicked my ass a
few times because people only see on the
bio they see the stuff that I pulled off
successfully all right it doesn't list
all the failures so cooking really it
kicked my ass a few times and I thought
well my readers have been asking me for
a book on accelerated learning a long
time and I've studied it for you 10 15
years starting with smart drugs in
college and all sorts of craziness so I
decided to take cooking because it had
beaten me so many times number one I and
use that as the storytelling and the
adventures for teaching all these
principles about you know learning
languages in 8 to 12 weeks or the
basketball the swimming the
sharpshooting whatever right and what
you find is that just like you trained
in badminton and found all these
principles that transcend it to other
things but the kitchen in a weird way is
like the ultimate dojo for her for
self-actualization because you have five
senses to play with it incorporates all
the senses so when you learn certain
principles that apply in the kitchen and
you mean you literally could spend five
to ten minutes twice a week he doesn't
it doesn't take a lot of time it
transcends to everything else which was
really really cool and one of the one of
the things that really surprised me was
how even if you practice cooking for a
week with a good logical progression you
which which at which I have it's hard to
find but if you do that even if you
never cook again you go from tasting
food in black and white like hot cold
good bad too like HD with a million
colors which is pretty sweet on where
you start collecting flavors like
baseball cards and then you're able to
just experience food in a totally
different way and you're going to do
that anyway I mean you're going to eat
you might not cook for you surely going
to eat all right well that's awesome I
mean yeah I'm think we're gonna touch
more on that later but I wanted to move
on to kind of like your most success on
your you know most successful book to
date as of now which is obviously the
4-hour workweek and you know in this
book you kind of teach the concept of
letting go the old formula of like you
know working in working in life of like
you know nine-to-five jobs and then
retiring like you know at your old age
you know to experiencing the freedom of
traveling while still you know gaining a
monthly income of like you know up to
five figures and it will take 0
management so um you know what do you
say to skeptics and people who don't
think that this is possible well
fortunately you know the book came out
in 2007 so it's the skeptics I'm like
search you know for HW success story and
youtube and watch a couple hundred
people tell you why exactly how they've
already done it don't think ya know so
that's that's great I mean fortunately I
have a very engaged audience and uh
whether it's through the blog or
otherwise I mean there are hundreds of
people who have put up case studies in
tracked and recorded it exactly how they
did what you just described so it's
easier now to the naysayer suggest say
you know just basically say do your
goddamn dude intelligence or like we're
not going to have a discussion about it
because there's nothing inherently
preventing it and I think that whether
you look at let's say the 4-hour
workweek which came out two thousand
seven but a lot of people don't realize
is before our body is actually selling
or has for a long time we're selling at
five times the rate of four hour work
week so it's actually probably it's it's
on track to be more successful in
foreign work week which is kind of wild
but if you look at all the books what I
do they're primarily two things that I
do number one is I look for anomalies
right I look for people who are uncommon
or ridiculously good at something and
become good at it in short
and then I try to dissect that and
replicate those results and sometimes
you find crazy people or freaks of
nature and other times you find you know
like the mother of two can travel six
months out of the year with the kids and
make really incredible income with a
side business and that is a recipe that
you can replicate and that's also true
with the body right you find let's say a
coach there's a guy again down your neck
li with me Barry Ross who trains high
school and collegiate track athletes and
his runners break World Records and if
you meet one of his female runners for
instance like a sophomore in high school
130 pounds she can deadlift 450 pounds
for repetitions no crabs no belt with
nothing and she looks like the average
like high school chick there's nothing
unusual about it and and when I then
tried to apply his method because I was
like well I'm not an elite Your Honor
you know and you can even see the result
like the excuses start to bubble up but
I was alright we put that aside I'll try
it and I went from a max deadlift of
like 315 because my hands were really
weak to very comfortably without any
wraps pulling from my knees no belt with
chalk like 650 pounds for five
repetitions which is recorded in like
when Morgan Spurlock's team came down
and did a day in the life with tim
ferriss I guess all you can see it and
it's like I can do that comfortably from
training check this out less than five
minutes of total muscle tension for the
entire week it's like it's it's
incredibly minimalist it's hard to
believe until you see it and well I in
the skeptics but I have too many I have
too many case studies too pointy on so I
don't take them too seriously yeah you
got the results already so it's really
hard to argue against you no solid proof
yeah yeah me it's like like it's 400
videos with that satisfy of 200,000 yeah
it's just bull and you just want to pick
like you're not you're not a reasonable
person so right right right like I'm
okay and I think this is the general
good policy in life is that you can't
reason someone out of a position they
didn't reason themselves into mmm
they'll pick your battles wisely mmm one
hundred percent agree
alright cool one of the what would you
say are the characteristics that a
person needs in order to you know apply
the 4-hour workweek model to its fullest
potential I think the the
characteristics are their
characteristics in their habits in both
cases you could say they need to view
themselves as an experimentalist in a
scientist they need to run experiments
and two-week trials a lot of the time
whether it's the law information diet or
applying the 8020 rule looking at the
twenty percent of let's say products and
services that produce eighty percent of
their income or the twenty percent of
activities in a job that produce eighty
percent or more of how they were
measured at let's say quarterly or
annual reviews for raises etc viewing
those exercises as one or two week
trials and doing those as experiments is
very important I'd say secondly would be
fear setting well in the fear setting is
the same as goal-setting but you're
identifying the worst case scenarios of
whatever decisions you're considering
making that you've been postponed it and
it's very simple exercise so you write
down the things you're considering doing
on let's say left-hand side of a piece
of paper then you write down the another
column the worst things that could
happen in detail I get detailed because
fear of failure or bad outcome is how
people postpone action it's too vague so
just like goals you can't overcome your
fears unless they're clear so you get
really specific about the worst-case
scenarios exactly how much money you
could lose exactly which relationships
you could destroy any cetera well next
column the things you could do to
minimize the likelihood of those things
happening and then very last column the
things you could do to get back to where
you are if those bad if those bad things
happen and it gives you tremendous power
than to move forward with certain types
of decisions like quitting your job
getting a new job taking six months off
taking let's say for entrepreneur you
know how this is I mean taking the two
away from your business that's that's
terrifying and how do you put systems in
place how do you create autonomous
decision-making allowing empowering
employees or contracted employees to do
in your place even if they can only do
it fifty percent as well and i think the
the last characteristic would be more of
a philosophical operating system which
is you have to get comfortable letting
the small bad things happen if you want
to get the big good things done and if
you want to have a very high output
business and a very high enjoyment live
and have control of your time you need
to get good at accepting the small bad
guys and letting those things happen
actively is the only other option is
micromanaging every aspect of your life
and that's self-defeating mmm I like
that I like that a lot um you know
you're moving on to kind of like the way
you marketed your first book right you
note in your past interviews that one of
the reasons why you know your first book
was successful is that you took a
bottom-up approach in terms of as
opposed to the you know old top-down
approach and so kind of for the sake of
our readers kind of explain like what
the bottom of a coach is because for me
personally I feel that you know it's
super super important for anyone that's
trying to make a living online whether
as an artist or a businessman yes the
the bottom up approach meant looking
very closely at how marketing was
evolving and how sales is evolving so
for instance when I when I begin to
write four hour work week I saw out
people who have been on the bestseller
list saying two or three years ago and
you have records of all the New York
Times bestseller list so you can find
this and I interviewed them I
interviewed about 12 best writing
authors should want a lot of awards
booker prize is peeled surprise etc on
how to write a good book then i also
interviewed 12 best-selling authors not
always the same thing about the the
areas that were most productive so least
input for the most output and then also
the biggest waste of time and there is a
consensus the consensus was radio sells
books good radio cells both legs like
NPR television is decreasing and
importance but if you can get a long
segment on a on a good television
channel it will absolutely move the
needle and then blogs are absolutely
floating like a rocket ship in
importance and that book tours are a
waste of time so those were those were a
few patterns in the data and so I began
to remember this actually really clearly
this December 26 something about those
summer 26th 2006 where I had gathered
all this data I was like well I guess
it's time for me to figure out what a
blog is and I didn't know anything about
it and sat down so I like start googling
like 8 100 most influential blogs I
don't even think tech marana existed at
that point yeah maybe and what I decided
I decided a few things i'll try to keep
it somewhat short but the best way to
reach bloggers is not via email so email
is the most crowded channel that's how
they must get hit look there's the most
noise it's hard to stick out as a signal
phone is with inconveniencing and still
a crime channel so what I decided to do
is rather than spend dozens or hundreds
of hours trying to chase down people
through those two media I went to trade
shows and went to a handful trade shows
like South by Southwest which is much
lighter of course and went to the blog
world expo or whichever events I could I
could I could get a hold of and I would
spend time in the hallways and not spend
time at the bars that's pretty much it
but what I also did is I would go up to
moderators on panels and I would explain
to them what I was up to very soft pitch
very soft finish bag I'm writing my
first book I don't know anything about
this i'm eager to learn them a good
student i'm very coachable here a little
bit of there's a little bit of my
background for credentials just so they
don't think you're some kook is there
anyone here you think i would enjoy
talking to maybe like yeah i go talk to
that guy so I go over and talk to that
guy and I'd say ohhh so and so said we
might get along just figured I'd inches
myself is my first time here out of the
only buddy and I would ask them a lot of
questions that did this at bars to see
like a group of say bloggers or whatever
and I'd walk up and I said you mind if i
if i eavesdropped is my first time at
this event I don't know anybody they be
like it's kind of weird whatever sure
and so I I'd ask questions like if they
said blah blah blah ruby-on-rails
didn't know if that was I think you know
I'm really sorry I'm on the in the deep
end of the ignorance pool here like what
is Ruby on Rails and i would ask
questions about what they're up to talk
with and eventually whether it was one
person or people they'd be like so what
what do you do exactly like well you
know I run this business but I'm
finishing up my first book and dotted on
it out and then I'd stop and I wait to
see who asked well what's it about if
they asked me that I'll give them the
answer and at the end of those
conversations I never said can we do an
article on your block can we do a blob
of I never pitched I said if you like
you know I don't think you'd like the
whole book it's book so long they take a
lot of time but there are two chat and I
think you would really like if it was
true and I'd say if you'd like i have a
bunch of advanced copies i don't know
who to send them to and i would i'd be
happy to just send you one and put a put
a sticky note on 20 pages i think you'd
like expect you to write about it
nothing just i'd be happy to send it to
you and they're like sure you know five
times out of ten they're they're pretty
cool bit and that's that's how the title
wave started then it was super soft
pitch and refined marketing so the way I
define marketing is knowing exactly who
your market is product market fit so I
never sent a book to anyone for whom it
didn't make perfect sense for those 20
pages that i said that i was
laser-focused and surgical and so it
wasn't it was no brainer for many of
them that they would give it to their
audiences it was good content custom
targeted to their readers or listeners
so that's how it happened and then I
went to South by Southwest I came out my
book came out in April and I went south
by southwest just prior to that and I
gave a presentation the first ever real
presentation at a big event like that
and I rehearsed at my friend's house
down the street actually by talking to
his three chihuahuas eat your waffles
and if you did it up content right but
they give you were in deep they all sat
down and if you weren't engaging as a
presenter they just like turn around and
start scratching their hear something so
I was measuring my success by if I could
get two hours to just
enraptured staring and I don't think
I've ever told that story book and and
then I went in and I killed it I
prepared really really hard I did that
presentation by a hundred times before I
gave it and it got the same South by
Southwest Twitter had launched it is the
it was the launch of Twitter at least
the first public launch and that was the
tipping point man like everything
changed that point on well that's that's
that's how it happened that's amazing I
think that really transcends to uh you
know uh like I told you before I'm a lot
of her readers are you know aspiring
like YouTube creators and everything I
think that this and one of the biggest
questions they ask me is you know how do
they go out about to collaborate with
you know other youtubers and you know to
create content and thereby helping you
know promote their channel and some of
the Vice I always give is like yeah 10
attend meetups attend you know trade
shows events like a vid con that focus
on you know your type of niche and then
just go out and talk to people and then
so yeah and don't be pushing it doesn't
work if it's a fit and you're in your
clear communicator and you're very calm
and not pushing if it's a great fit
they'll say yes if it's not a great fit
because you've been too lazy to do your
homework then the heart of your pitch is
the more they're going to hate you so do
your homework know thy audience it's
that simple honest I mean and yes you
have to be persistent in some cases but
there's a there's a fine line between
being persistent and a huge pain in the
ass and I think that there's a there's a
there's a misconception that you know to
hustle means to be pushy that's not true
the Hustle is to be like a special ops
intelligence officer where you plan
everything down to the my new detail if
this then X if this then why and you
have a very concrete well thought out
plan that is proper hustle so anyway
those are those some my fon central the
resources that i would recommend people
read if they want if they really want to
get I think a refined and practical
grasp of marketing with timeless
principles that don't expire I would say
the 22 immutable laws of marketing
by reefs are AES and trout to the 22
immutable laws of marketing not for the
Internet get the older one they did one
put like the Internet information
superhighway which is not good get the
old one where they give examples of like
an imported beer there's an airplay you
know airlines and stuff and then and
then I'd say second and third to our
articles you can get online 1000 true
fans by kevin kelly whose founding
editor of Wired and then i believe it's
called the truth about social media
which is a very boring title but driven
by tim o'reilly so Tim 0 ' Riley you who
runs o'reilly media and he is a real
thought leader and as an impeccable
prediction right successful it with
prediction over the last 10 20 years in
technology but book you read those three
things you could do all three in in one
day this weekend next weekend whatever
you'll be ahead of ninety-nine percent
of marketers or for sure awesome i'll
definitely uh you know link those an
article cool okay well kind of moving on
so that you kind of answered it but what
do you think are the biggest factors in
achieving success on the internet being
different i I think that you can try to
be the best in a crowd of niche all day
long but that's a very hard battle and I
think that being different and niching
down so you know I'll give you a teaser
who your thousand true fans are so if
you if you can satisfy the Walter needs
of a thousand people who belong to very
specific demographic and and make those
people die hard fans who will support
you through thick and thin you never
have to buy another ad you never have to
do any more marketing for the rest of
your life that sounds like an
overstatement it's not i can tell you i
mean i have a blog gets about 1.2
million uniques a month right now I post
every two three four weeks doesn't make
much of a difference in my audience
sticks with me because I don't want to
put out a lot of content that people
merely like I want to put out content
maybe if it's once a week
it's once a month great once a year fine
i will only want to put out content that
people love and it takes it takes a lot
of focus to do that it's a lot easier to
keep the wheels spinning so i would say
that being different and then I really
carefully choosing you know those
thousand people and that doesn't mean
you go out and find them on the internet
necessarily it means that you create a
product with those thousand people in
mind so when I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I mean I didn't have a blog I didn't
have anything and I wrote that book the
only way I got that book out because I
tried to write I find writing heart I
really do so when I was hurt let's go
okay at first it came out I went to
Princeton undergrad and I go back and
teach in high tech entrepreneurship so I
see your usual but at first i read this
is really like pompous princeton speak
it was just this like oh my god it was
terrible so I wrote a couple of chapters
I threw it all out when I was like no no
no I need to be for casual so that I
tried that and it was like this stupid
Three Stooges slapstick it was just a
horrible on the obstinate so I had to
throw that out and then what I decided
finally was i'm going to write this like
a like a like a letter to my two or
three closest friends we have all the
same problems the ones that after you
know two three years of experimenting i
figured out so i would have two glasses
of wine and then i would start writing
as a part of writing to my best friends
and it's the only way i got the book out
so anyway maybe a bit of a digression
but that was knowing my audience you
know I had to exact people in mind so
happens that you take like archetype
like one of them was a guy who got
seduced by investment banking went into
I banking was working 80 to 100 hour
weeks making crazy money you know
finally bought his favorite car he
bought a Porsche and you know I asked
him a few weeks after he bought it like
how's it going to so excited when he
called me bear he's like how is the
Porsche I don't know it's in my garage
it's dust on it I haven't used it no
it's just like wow like that's an
archetype there are thousands of people
who are in that exact same situation so
writing from this person even though I
was writing for one person is actually
hitting a thousand true fans in that
demographic and that's very clearly
defined like 20 you know twenty to
twenty seven-year-old investment banker
right out of school you could also make
it McKinsey or whatever like I know
those people by very intimately sending
them I don't want to drag on and on but
I think being important knowing who your
top thousand targets are now I think
that's really important for like knowing
your audience I think that that's that's
the key thing that if anybody should
take in is probably that I think that's
really important so um yeah moving on so
I read somewhere that you believe that
technology today such as email instant
messaging and Internet enabled PDAs
complicate life rather than simplify you
know can you kind of touch more on this
and does this link does this list
include like social media outlets today
since you know now it's heavily you know
heavily prevalent in this day and age
yeah so that was yeah that was a those
debate that I moderated for was it The
Economist it was the bait that I
moderated economists we had I guess it
was I think it's John Maeda of RISD
president of RISD on some other
gentleman in any case I think that in a
digital world there's always more
information and always more demand for
your attention then you can possibly
contend with so it's important to to
focus on output you have to limit input
that's the way I look at it so is is
instant people begin to expect instant
access and they send you a text and if
you don't reply back in five minutes
then they're like what's wrong what's
going on yeah whatever you it's
important to be able to reestablish
barriers and you can use tech tools to
help do that even for self behavior so
for instance use tools like rescue time
to block certain sites for certain hours
so you can't access them on your
computer to be very valuable like
Facebook Twitter and I mean full
disclosure I mean I'm an investor about
early investor in facebook and twitter
so my sort of side life is is advising
and investing in startups so it's like
between 25 and 30 companies since 2007
so that would include uber stumble
Evernote Shopify it's a good list I've
been very fortunate to work with some
excellent companies but they'll all say
the same thing I mean to get a lot done
you need to ignore the vast majority of
things that come out here develop that
through discipline you can develop that
through philosophical so if operating
system like stoicism I'm a huge fan of
letters from a stoic my Seneca it's
probably my closest thing to Bible that
I have and you can also use systems Sol
system another system example would be
email game so email jmb which allows you
to process gmail and about fifty percent
of the time that it would usually take
because ever see the inbox it's just a
sequential start to finish timed per
message clearance of the inbox to inbox
zero and you can schedule your most for
later delivery you can schedule emails
for reminders if you don't hear back
within several days it's it's incredible
it's a very simple tool but very very
effective yeah and I think that a lot of
these principles are not new I mean the
the tools in the toolbox might be new
but I know mentioning a lot of books
obviously I don't expect everyone to
read them but the effective executive
written by Peter Drucker's but most
famous management nearest to the last
hundred years also just a very effective
guy you'd hope of course but he and for
instance you probably know Paul Graham
of Y Combinator they the highest
performance the highest performers
whether that's in the world of chefs the
world of sports the world startups they
all do the same stuff and for instance
Peter Drucker talks about how it was a
two to three blocks two to three hour
blocks of time is critical for someone
who wants to create somebody wants to be
a maker instead of a manager and that no
collection of let's say 20 minute breaks
no collection 20 min race will ever
equal one three-hour block of time just
like nope flexion of one week vacations
will ever have the impact of 12 month
vacation they're just fundamentally
different and the polygon has an
excellent essay which you can read
online something along the lines of the
maker versus the manager schedule and it
talks about this but
self-discipline operating system so
stoicism for me and then systems I think
those are those are three keys nice that
kind of outlines your 2080 rule crack we
think that Pareto's law so that's that's
when the 18 that gets the mid-to-late
1800s it was when this lock-in about but
I getting very good at identifying the
twenty percent of activities the twenty
percent of fill in the blank anything
that produce eighty percent of the
results that you want or more and you
find that with investing you find that
with content creation certainly I mean
you look at my youtube channel it's like
I have what you know of how to how to
peel eggs without peeling them where
you're like blow an egg out of the shell
which is pretty cool and that has four
million semi views and of course that's
like I don't know what the percentages
in my total views but it's it's well
over ninety percent and I think that you
see that in most places there are a few
things that provide very
disproportionate returns that's true
with services it's true products it's
true with customers so I built and sold
a sports nutrition company at one point
we had 120 different hotel customers
around the world and it was a headache
to manage I mean it was like 50 60 hours
a week just to manage those customers
and when I did an 8020 analysis of the
profit per customer we found that
something like five of the customers
were delivering ninety percent of the
revenue and but we were fully with the
high maintenance customers were the
people in the other 95 the other 115 so
you're spending all our time on the
people who gave us the least return on
investment so we changed our systems
basically said look and if you want to
place an order here's an automated
system for doing so and then we focused
on profiling and replicating those most
profitable customers and getting those
most profitable customers to buy even
larger orders more frequently and boom
it was like profits increase the a340
percent a few weeks and the amount of
time required to management went for
like 60 hours a week to two hours ago
and it literally just from sitting down
with an Excel spreadsheet had it we're
figuring it out like an afternoon
and it's important to take and if you're
if you're unable to take two to three
hours to do that you're going to be
caught in the hamster wheel forever so
scheduling those breaks is really
important nice cool great so we're going
to move on to a YouTube here um you know
so many big celebrities and businesses
are not taking advantage of YouTube and
other online video outlets to build
their brand what are your general
thoughts of the recent boom of interest
and new media entertainment well I think
it's the future I mean there's no doubt
that I mean we're definitely moving from
a predominantly network broadcast model
to you see the iteration of let's say
highly diversified cable networks and
then even more highly diversified
certainly online channels and networks
television still holds a very special
spot in the minds of the global populace
including the u.s. so for instance if
you take if you take any any of the top
10 most subscribed youtube channels they
might have and say 3 plus million
subscribers but the average American is
still going to be more impressed if they
have a cable show that gets five hundred
thousand years wait okay so the way that
you leverage these different outlets
depends a lot on what your objective is
right so if your objective is to get
sponsored by Nike or someone like that
you might actually get a higher price if
you focus on an outlet like cable with a
much smaller ultimate audience the way
the machinery works right now with
interactions between whether it's a CAA
and Nike an ad agency that that is the
most efficient model but that's going to
change that's going to change real fast
and certainly I'm more interested in the
YouTube channel that I am in the TV show
because if you're if you're looking to
actually sell product and track it which
very few companies do properly / outlet
then having one click to buy through a
single author blog or a personality
driven youtube channel is much more
interesting than a much more interesting
unit morning america for a minute three
minutes where people need to remember it
and then right
down and go to the computer it's the
conversions terrible not interested
right do it if I'm in New York fantastic
it's fun but from a strict roi
standpoint I mean obviously everything
moving to digital you get the beauty of
the call to action to when it comes to
do to them you know online outlets
absolutely absolutely it's just a much
more flexible malleable experimental
outlet and me and medium in television
that there aren't as many experiments
being run because they have a model that
is very reliable for generating certain
amount of revenue on a quarterly basis
and you have publicly traded companies
response on YouTube you have you know
thousands tens of thousands God knows
how many independent creators all of
them can experiment as an officer as
always a lot so of course they're going
to be ahead of the curve eventually and
certainly when you see people like epic
meal time being signed to the collective
and I mean the production value for
these videos is is a prize television no
question and that's just going to
continue to be the case well and what
you mentioned that you had a YouTube
channel as well I did some research and
I found the you had a you to kind of
forward before our body yeah and so my
question is how big of an impact does
YouTube have right now are currently
when it comes to marketing your books
well the 4-hour body channel was
established for a few different reasons
uh I did do a very high cinematic value
trailer which means I mean it really
does look like a movie trailer so it's
not the typical just like enough text on
screen kind of talking head nonsense lat
nonsense but it's just not very very
interesting or sexy so I created that
channel to ship the case that video
which i think has close to a million
views law and that video was all to be
also repurposed for many other uses when
you're in broadcaster elsewhere the
other reason it's important to have a
youtube channel for our body or for our
chef is to prevent squatters from
holding your brand hostage so if you
launch a product these days like having
your product name calm is not enough you
need every single variation you possibly
think of on every single out like that
you can boss your finger and to do
otherwise is irresponsible because it
will bite you in the ass I guarantee you
mmm yeah I like that all right I have a
couple fish guys yeah google
self-defense is really important
learning learning google self-defense is
a critical skill for anyone who wants to
be have a lot have longevity online with
business for sure oh okay great love it
i have a couple of fan questions for you
first one is from twitter and uh Adam
Zhang asses who's the single most
influential person to your success and
why all right I can't give just one
answer I mean my parents obviously but
that's a given that's it's kind of a
gimme you might buy parents were very
good exposing me to a lot so that I
naturally became interested in learning
because they exposed me that you know
100 things when I really like something
and they would encourage it but let me
give a few other answers I'll give one
other answer wrestling coach John Buxton
who produced an incredible team and this
was at a prep high school I went from
public school to private high school
after buddy minus stabbed in the leg in
private high school and John Buxton what
an amazing amazing coach he he was not
he not only took kitling you know kids
with very poor raw materials and and
turned them into incredibly good
wrestlers I mean I was I did I was I did
not start with much Andy and I was I was
a American by the end of high school
thanks to him but he also was
multifaceted he raised the endowment of
st. Paul's for me i'm just guessing
someone about 50 million five hundred
million in the same period of time he
was also an english teacher and when you
look at the people who came out of that
team like Charles best to co the
nonprofit called donors choose which
which I advise and they were the first
nonprofit ever too fast company's most
50
the most creative companies in the world
or innovative companies in the world you
look at every single person on that team
and you asked them the same question you
just asked me and they all say John
buckstone that on Oprah not too long ago
and yeah the man had a medicine bag and
it's yeah that's a simple answer I mean
he really taught us to believe in
ourselves and he absolutely beat the
living hell out of us with so that
whatever we do now it's like yeah well
wasn't as bad as you know ten nine eight
so with mr. buckston no way wasn't close
to his heart so makes it makes
everything else they'll kind of easy in
comparison which is great it's a good
lesson that's awesome great great story
the second fan questions also from
Twitter and it's about dating and she
asses is there a way that you can fit
gaining into a 4 in 24 hours a week and
still find that special someone yeah I
think so I mean I did an experiment
where I outsource my dating for a while
I hired um I actually put a basically a
proposal request for proposal on elance
i guess it was and assembled teams from
around the planet around the planet like
Philippines India Mexico Jamaica even
and they were each given one of my
profiles so whether it's match com yahoo
personals whatever and that they
couldn't say they remain so they had to
be like you know this is Venkatesh
writing on behalf of Tim Ferriss but
they were allowed to DM girls and they
had all the criteria that all the specs
means very businesslike and their job
was to compete to set coffee dates for
free so I had a weekend because at first
it was like I can do you know four to
five on this day in 72 the 830 on this
day and was too complicated so I said
look we're gonna do a weekend Saturday
Sunday every day all day I just want you
to pack this schedule full of coffee
dates that's it and so I had three
coffee shops on this main street in san
jose i was living at the time nice went
from one concept to the next to the next
back and forth and back and forth back
forth lil awkward when you have like one
girl leaving another one coming in but
that's why you have to alternate but
long story short is i met a great girl
that way we ended up dating for about
six months I mean it was it was
definitely that that was more successful
than everything I tried in San Jose
which is nicknamed man Jose more more
successful than everything I tried in
San Jose fer I guess two years prior and
that included like going out to the bars
and going out to the restaurants and
like doing all that like long-form stuff
and you know I hate to say it but it's
like you know banking Tash and all those
guys did a better job in one weekend and
all that and it cost me about between
150 and 250 bucks it's like less than
two dinners you know is so yeah you can
definitely do it you can definitely but
I would say that you strive for the
4-hour workweek so you can actually
spend a proper amount of time choosing
your your mate but yeah you can
certainly scream on it well that about I
love it awesome I'm going my last few
questions are going to be talking about
your book and you put your new book the
4-hour chef is set for release on
November 20th correct yeah that's white
and aside from you know the obvious some
house is different from like your last
book and you know what are some things
that we can look forward to and what are
some things that you did differently in
terms of the process of writing this
book yeah yeah absolutely this this book
I have a couple of my friends you're
reading and have read advance copies and
a few of them said that this is their
favorite of the three so I'm super
psyched I mean the book is very
different than the past two books in
many ways number one it has more than
1,500 photographs it has I reached out
to some interesting folks so i have on
Calvin and Hobbs Hobbs cartoons i have
victoria secret supermodels I've got you
know snipers i have like everything in
this there's some for everybody but it's
really a choose your own adventure guide
to learning so anything even if you
don't care about cooking that's fine but
the the stories that i give our through
trying to explore this skill i found
very intimidating and very overwhelming
and time consuming which was cooking so
a few things i did differently in terms
of a process so i used evernote to do
all my research and gather all my
research I used sketch for screenshots I
used ScreenFlow 4 designed feedback a
base camp for organizing
all my teens I'll come back to that then
a Dropbox for sharing all my big files
with my teams and I i we pulled out all
the stops I mean this is Amazon
Publishing's first major acquisition
it's their biggest bug and we had teams
not only in New York California Los
Angeles Chicago we had a couple of dozen
photographers we had illustrators all
over the planet like Singapore Australia
you name it and it's a monster I mean in
a good way but I'll leave it at that I
mean what I would say is you know life
is short even if you're you know 18 19
it's time to get started accelerating
and multiplying your learning potential
and that is the best way to squeeze the
most out of every single hour you have
whether that's in your business life
your personal life hobbies whatever
because I do think it's possible to
become world class in one or two things
per year not for lifetime and I think
I've done a pretty good job of
demonstrating that not only yeah can I
do it and because I figured out an
approach to it but my readers have been
able to do it that's the cool part
because i'll try all this crazy [ __ ] and
be the human guinea pig but then i'll
say all right here's how i learned how
to swim and literally i have people who
have like printed out a blog post on to
the pool never been able to swim and
leave being able to turn 20 laps and
that's the fun stuff so i hope that
every single person that you know after
reading it and it's a choose your own
adventure book so i don't expect anyone
to read more than 50 to 100 pages at a
time but they will they will look at
these skills that they've put off or
skills they've dreamed of acquiring like
playing the guitar playing the violin
whatever that they will like look go
horns ahead and just charge right for it
because that's where the fun is it's
nice I mean I think that you mentioned
your book is more so about the skill
learning skills that you mentioned here
as opposed to just a cookbook and um you
know can you share some quick tip bits
of what one of these skills are that are
outlined in the book yeah absolutely so
I talked about for instance reversal
trying things backwards right and there
are some really in there they're just
simple questions basically that people
can use to make faster progress
so for instance I'll give you a couple
of quick examples like what if you built
a fire backwards and so you start with
the biggest logs on the bottom and then
move up to the kindling at the top it
turns out you can actually make a fire
that burns like two three times more
effectively by building it upside down
what if in swimming you didn't kick it
all which is a reason a lot of people
quit right they're like hey here's a
kickboard go do five laps and exhausting
you don't move and you give up so what
if you could do it without kicking it
all turns out there's a method total
immersion swimming it allows you to
pretty much do that even what if you
could cook with no cleanup zero club
like how would you engineer that how
would you make that happen turns out
there a lot of ways to do it um for
instance like you wanna make the perfect
steak I'll just tell you right now like
the way to make perfect steak there you
go get it rib eye that's an inch and a
half thick I'm going to Pat it dry click
put a ton of salt on the top leave it
alone for an hour and a half the water
is going to come out of the steak mix
with salt and be reabsorbed okay then
you wipe off any extra salt throw it in
the freezer for 45 minutes okay and
elevate it if you can the reason we put
it in the freezer is to evaporate as
much surface moisture as possible that's
the only reason so that's a freezing
stick so it's to make the surface as dry
as possible so you can get the best sear
via something called the by our reaction
so then take it out you have the oven
set to 200 degrees really low get a
skillet screaming hot put in some
grapeseed oil or whatever can throw in
some pepper flakes if you like into the
oil which is amazing and then you sear
that sucker you take tongs like 30-60
seconds each side and then what you're
going to do this is the end this happy
real quickly pick it up with tongs put a
bunch of like rosemary underneath I mean
it could be a freaking stock it doesn't
really matter what I mean is the
rosemary serves two purposes of flavors
of steak but it also keeps it from
touching the metal so it doesn't
overcook on that side you get a probe
thermometer that you already have this
right and then this is in my gear
section like I tested thousands types of
gear and I'm basically here's what you
get if your budgets 50 bucks here's what
you get if your budget stupid you're not
get a probe the bars twenty bucks stick
in the mill mistake set an alarm bro
35 degrees and then you leave that
thermometer in because the sort of
display stays outside of the stove you
throw it in at 200 degrees 15 to 20
minutes later you're done pull out the
stake pour some of the juices on top of
it and you'll have the best steak you've
ever had in your life that is the
perfect steak and something that you can
learn and get right every single time
you'll never have to worry if it's
undercooked overcooked it will be
perfect every single time that's our
recipe should work whether it's for that
languages or otherwise so that's kind of
what my goal was oh man I want to try
that tonight actually oh and if you want
to go nuts if you really want to go nadz
just get some ghee which is clarified
butter right so it's kind of like slow
carb compliant my diet like slow carb
compliant butter yeah it'll burn like
butter so you can raise it you can you
can cook it at higher temperatures and
and put that on top right when you get
it out and let it melt on the stake oh
it's amazing man sounds amazing I'm I
might actually try that it might replay
this later oh yeah try manage tolet
rides it's an IV yet to make it for
anyone including a lot of like manly men
who cook a lot of steaks in different
ways and they're just like dude that's
amazing pessimism definitely definitely
try it out great and then so let's see
um and not the last question i have is
where is the best place people can
pre-order your new book yeah the best
place so this this this book is
fascinating because it's it's the like i
said first major book from amazon
publishing so it's being boycotted by
barnes noble and a lot of big retailers
so go to good amazon and I really
designed this book for print because you
can open it up kind of like a comic book
and you get the spread but it's also in
digital I mean it's great in digital but
i think it's optimal in print and I want
to make if I could just 11 offer to
folks because it's it's it's really a
holiday book and that is if you're
interested in a two-hour live Q&A with
me and I'll just grab some wine you can
ask me anything you want by three print
copies of the book one for you and two
gifts and just email the amazon receipt
to three books at 4-hour chef Duff um so
the number three books at for our shaft
the number four for our chef calm and
then
but so if you'd like to do a two-hour
live Q&A with me ask me whatever you
want after launch week just get three
print copies and send it you know cool
awesome we'll be sure to link that on
the bottom and everything all right
great I'm going to go ahead stop the
recording now so thanks a lot for
joining us i really appreciate their
time